[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى موجز الانباء عقد امير دوله
قطر الشيخ تميم بن حمد ال ساري مباحثات في
الدوحه مع رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني عبد
الفتاح البرهان وقالت ديون الاميري امير
دوله قطر جدد التاكيد على موقف بلاده
الداعي الى وقف القتال وانتاج الحوار
وصولا الى اتفاق السلام شامل ومسلم من جهه
قال المتحدث باسم الخارجيه القطريه مسجد
الانصاري للجزيره ان قطر تبدي استعدادها
للمساهمه باي شكل ايجابي لحل الازمه
السودانيه
هذا وقال البرهان في حديثه للجزيره ان
الاولويه هي انهاء ما سماه التمرد مضيفا
ان القوات المسلحه ماضيه في استكمال
المرحله الانتقاليه والانتقال الى حكم
مدني ديمقراطي
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه احباط هجوم
اوكرانيا بمسيرتين على منطقه الروسيه في
المقابل افادت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه
بان القوات الروسيه نفذت 74 غاره جويه
وشنت 46 هجوما صاروخيا على مواقع تابعه
للجيش الاوكراني
اعلن البنتاغون تقديم مساعدات عسكريه
جديده لاوكرانيا بقيمه 600 مليون دولار
وقال ان قذائفا اليورانيوم المنظم الخاصه
بدبابات ابرز التي ستسلم لاوكرانيا ستكون
الاكثر فعاليه في مواجهه الدبابات الروسيه
ووصف قرار الولايات المتحده تزويلا
اوكرانيا بقذائف اليورانيوم المنظم بالخبر
السيء للغايه وقال ان استخدامه سيتسبب في
عواقب وخيمه كما حمل واشنطن عواقب استخدام
هذه القذاء في معارك اوكرانيا
قال مسؤول عسكري امريكي للجزيره انه سيتم
اعاده نشر عدد من افراد القوات الامريكيه
والعتاد داخل النيجر واشار الفانتاغون الى
ان القرار اجراء الاحترازي وانه لا وجود
لتهديد ملموس لقوته هناك
نفى مفوض اقواس خوض المجموعه نقاشات مع
قاده الانقلاب في النجر مشيرا الى ان
المجموعه لم تحدد تاريخا للتدخل العسكري
وانها تمنح الفرصه لعمليات الوساطه
قال رئيس الوزراء الارميني اذربيجان حشدت
قوتها على طول خط التماس مع كرباخ والحدود
مع ارمينيا ودع المجتمع الدولي لمنع وقوع
ما سماه انفجار جديدا في المنطقه
في المقابل وصفت اذربيجان اتهامات يرمينيا
لها بالتلاعب السياسي محذره من وضع عقبات
امام اتفاقات السلام
تجددت صباح اليوم الاشتباكات المسلحه في
مخيم عين الحلوه للاجئين الفلسطينيين في
جنوب لبنان بين عناصر من حركه فتح واخرين
ينتمون الى مجموعه تطلق على نفسها اسم
الشباب المسلم
ختام الموجز الى اللقاء